entraînement de visibilité mondiale et
nous le ferons merci madame la parole
est à madame marianne dubois
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre les chiffres du chômage
dévoilés hier nous ont révélé une bien
mauvaise surprise
vous nous aviez promis une baisse
spectaculaire et à nouveau nous
constatons une augmentation vous
communiquer sur la tendance à la baisse
de la catégorie à
mais cette tendance semble bien fragile
puisque la réalité c'est que le nombre
de chômeurs augmente de 0 8% au total ce
sont 550 mille français de plus qu'en
2012 sans aucun emploi
en réalité les chiffres d'hier soir nous
apprennent une chose malgré tout vos
artifices vous n'arrivez pas à endiguer
la hausse du chômage malgré les contrats
aidés coûteux et peu efficace malgré le
plan 500000 formation
malgré une dizaine de lois pour rien la
courbe ne s'est pas inversée votre
quinquennat c'est 5 milliards d'euros d'
emplois d'avenir
ces deux milliards d'euros pour l'aide
en embauche pme dont le trésor redoutent
un effet nul d'ici cinq ans ce sont des
milliards de cice mal utilisé et qu'ils
n'ont pas rapporté le souffle d'air
espérer aux entreprises l'actualité des
groupes
whirpool et vive art en témoigne quel
gaspillage votre quinquennat c'est
l'échec des lois macro et l comrie une
inflation législative mais aucune
réforme structurelle avec des lois vidés
de leur substance à coups de 49 3
c'est le quinquennat des velléités et
pas de la volonté
au final à votre quinquennat c'est une
ardoise qui continue de s'alourdir avec
1,1 million de demandeurs d'emploi
supplémentaires depuis 2012 et aucune
explication ne peut justifier ce gâchis
je cite un collègue parlementaire qui
déclarait ce matin sur une chaîne
nationale
le bilan hélas du quinquennat sur ces
questions d'emploi restera négatif ce
collègue n'est autre que benoît hamon
monsieur premier ministre avez vous
conscience que derrière ces chiffres il
y à des femmes des hommes des familles
qui souffrent et qui se demandent de
quoi sera fait demain je vous remercie
merci la parole le cadre naturel premier
ministre bernard cazeneuve
madame la députée mesdames et messieurs
les députés
il n'a échappé à la sagacité de
personnes dans cet hémicycle que nous
sommes dans une période électorale que
cette période va conduire les
différentes formations politiques et les
candidats qui les représentent à
s'affronter qu'il est tout à fait normal
qu'il y ait un débat sur la politique de
l'emploi sur la politique économique si
hautement souhaitable pour éclairer les
choix des français et en même temps
madame la députée vous conviendrez avec
moi que ce débat si nous voulons qu'ils
soient de qualité et si nous voulons
être dans le respect de nos concitoyens
il doit s'articuler au fait à la réalité
des chiffres et à rien d'autre et c'est
donc d'abord à la réalité que je
voudrais faire référence est ce que le
chômage l'an dernier en france a baissé
ou pas la réponse est oui
il a baissé de 107 me le chômeur et il a
baissé de 107 me chômeurs parce que nous
avons mis en place une politique
extrêmement offensive depuis cinq ans
alors que nous avions trouvé vous ne
l'avez pas dit dans votre question
madame dubois une situation où il y
avait eu un million de chômeurs de plus
pendant le quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy ou 750 mille emplois industriels
avaient été détruits ou la compétitivité
des entreprises avaient été fortement
dégradés ou les marges des entreprises
avaient été laminés et nous avons parce
que nous voulions mené précisément des
politiques structurelles pris la
décision de changer cet ordre des choses
pour engager le pays dans un
redressement durable
qu'avons nous fait nous avons redresser
la compétitivité des entreprises vous
plaît si longtemps la mise en place du
pacte de respect à écouter la réponse
qu'ils resteraient de deux points les
marges des entreprises qui a permis à
l'investissement industriel madame
dubois de repartir cette année ils
étaient 3,4 pour cent
il était négatif lorsque vous avez
quitté le pouvoir nous avons créé deux
cent quarante mille emplois dans le
secteur marchand au cours des 18
derniers mois et le chômage des jeunes
et au moment où ce quinquennat s'achève
plus bas qu'ils ne l'étaient au moment
où vous avez quitté le pouvoir donc
lorsque vous posez des questions sur
notre politique je vous demande
simplement de restituer la réalité et de
ne pas être sur ce sujet comme sur les
autres dans la dissimulation
la manipulation de manière à éviter
d'avoir à rendre compte de ce que vous
avez fait lorsque vous étiez au pouvoir
au regard de ce que nous avons fait nous
mêmes et jeudi à la majorité dans son
ensemble quelles que soient les
sensibilités qui la traversent
soyez fiers d'avoir soutenu un
gouvernement qui pendant cinq ans a
contribué à restaurer la situation des
entreprises
soyez fiers d'avoir restauré les marges
des entreprises soyez fier d'avoir créé
les conditions d'une relance de l'emploi
industriel
soyez fiers d'avoir contribué à inverser
la tendance sur le chômage et soyez
fiers de contribuer aussi par le débat à
restituer ce qu'est la réalité du bilan
calamiteux du précédent quinquennat
[Applaudissements]
les cours d'étude
merci